knight contamine tout le monde il ay ay
l'arrêt clinton qui s'initient aux dames
il y à là danse d'un buteur en finale de
la coupe du monde de soccer
il ya ces millions de personnes qui
suivent en direct d'autres personnes qui
jouent on y arrive en chute libre et on
doit tout faire pour être le dernier
survivant passe à 100 joueurs comme
étaient onze les chiffres sont
étourdissants 200 millions de joueurs
3 milliards de dollars de bénéfices nets
en 2018
car oui jouer à forza et c'est gratuit
mais on peut y acheter plein de choses
tout est fait pour faire perdre le
contrôle
cette année des choses intéressantes et
crée des besoins qui existent pas
toujours chez cette spécialiste de la
cyberdépendance des deux garçons il n'y
a que le plus grand qui joue emilien 11
ans fait frapper loin et pour rétablir
des règles
c'était par essai erreur par exemple si
oui vous pouvez jouer 30 minutes par
jour puis ça faisait d'eux lâche quand
tous les jours donc lancé non ça n'est
pas la bonne stratégie c'est intolérable
pour nous finalement ce sera possible
certains jours d'école et un peu plus la
fin de semaine
quand j'ai paniqué là les gars là j'ai
vu ma vie défiler un son succès
phénoménal fortnight le doit en partie à
une autre psychologue qui a participé à
sa conception au sein du studio epic la
plus grosse question qu'on va avoir
c'est est ce que les joueurs vont
continuer de jouer c'est la plupart des
jeux échouent les mini duché ondes
mon ami momo déjà construit confesse
descente pe à l'écouté encore plus et si
de plus en plus de jeunes parlent le
même langage
c'est parce que x knight a très bien
compris ce qu'est liégeois a real on est
tous sens et mourant forcément donc plus
on vous dit que vous êtes bon tout ça va
être intéressant et il faut que les
défis soient suffisamment grand pour
vous tenir en éveil
mais pas trop grand parce que vous allez
abandonner et comme ils vous suivent en
direct
ils sont en mesure de savoir quand vous
allez abandonner
devant l'engouement mondial un animateur
vedette propose une vengeance aux
parents avoir contribué à créer ce genre
de comportement est c'est un cas de
conscience
imaginez que je sois que j'aide les
cuisiniers à faire des gâteaux chocolats
très bon à qui fait qu on est vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir contendant jaune est
au chocolat évidemment qu'il va y avoir
des gens qui vont pas pouvoir s'arrêter
ce qui est surtout important c'est de
protéger les enfants les adolescents les
adultes sont censés avoir suffisamment
de maturité pour s'auto discipliner et
toujours des gens qui veulent vont plus
et faire en sorte que les gens dépensent
plus qu'ils auraient souhaité c'est très
facile de dire à 10 $ 5 $ 1 au 10
dollars pièce boxe on pense qu'on a
dépensé 15 finalement on est rentré à 50
ce qu'elle regrette c'est que les jeux
ne propose aucune barrière
si vous étiez avec des jeux de hasard et
d'argent vous pourriez vous auto exclure
du jeu à 23,0 du lundi au jeudi où pour
quelques mois
c'est tout des notions qui n'existe pas
donc pour la responsabilité pour
protéger le joueur soit y en a pas et ça
je trouve ça un peu décevant parce que
si on a quelqu'un qui est spécialiste du
comportement
eh bien on aurait peut-être pu penser à
cet aspect là où c'est us et expliqué
que ce serait bien aussi de récompenser
se reposait après deux missions de
s'arrêter que ce soit pas tout le temps
on n'est pas toujours des récompenses à
l'engagement mais pour l'instant qu'en
repos il y a il est plutôt forcé je te
laisse la pince est accusé d'avoir le
top
non ici mathieu prost radio-canada à
montréal ça finit